title of my presentation is a bit
generic but I would like to just discuss
one idea to improve detection of
structural variations in multiple
genomes especially in cancer genomes so
there are so many experts in this room
so I would just like to motivate my talk
by saying that many diseases are caused
as a result of structural variations so
it's important to have accurate methods
to detect SVS so with next-generation
sequencing technologies these days we
can produce a lot of data very cheap and
fast however we have this limitation of
short reads and since the human genome
is very repetitive it's very challenging
to analyze genomes using just Shortridge
so most methods for detecting structural
variations are based on Risa qin Singh
so we would align reads apparently back
to reference genomes and look for
discordance it in the parent alignment
and we can do some structure version
event looking at these signals however
as I said since the genome has a lot of
repeats and most of the structure
variations are close to repetitive
regions the reference genome is
incomplete and some of the skills are
very complex it's very challenging to
find structural variation in cancer we
have been more problems because we have
mixture of tumor and normal cells
usually and then we have the problem of
cancer originating so we heard a lot
during the past couple of days about
this problem so I would mention one idea
we have I'm developing a tool car which
is called lab see lineage aided
parsimony structure variation inference
and the input to this program is
multiple whole genome sequencing data
and either in addition to that we have
also targeted deep sequencing of some of
somatic single nucleotide variants and
their corresponding variant allele
frequencies in the cells so this is an
example of the data set say
have several samples several cancer
samples including the match normal maybe
early neoplasia and different carcinomas
and we have also deep sequencing of say
1,000 somatic variants in something the
same patients so the goal of lab c is to
predict and genotype search a variation
in these samples and place them on the
link on the tumor lineage tree so the
main idea is to use the single or total
variance to build a lineage took a tumor
lineage tree and then use this tree as a
guide for detecting a structural
variation more accurately so this would
help us especially reduce the false
negative so the main assumption is that
the lineage trees for single nucleotide
variants are pretty much identical to
the lineage theory of a structural
variation and we would again favor the
perfect phylogeny model so this here is
a workflow first we would reconstruct
the lineage 3 using high-quality snv's
then we would cluster all the disco
dancer than the parent reads across all
the whole genome samples and then we
have an optimization algorithm to select
and place these searcher variation
clusters on the tree so I wouldn't talk
about the reconstruction part because we
heard it yesterday by Victoria stock but
we can also use other other available
tools to reconstruct the lineage tree so
here is an example when we use the
leechee algorithm on the various cancer
data we had we can get these trees
then you would cluster all the
discordant pair entries of the whole
genome sequencing data such that the
reads that support the same search of
variation events are pooled together we
can use we can use available tools such
as our own method common law to cluster
these break points so this would give if
we use all the genomes multiple genome
this would give us a matrix where the
rows are different samples and then we
have columns for different sv clusters
and these are the reed pair support in
each cluster for each stamp so the main
idea is to assign what I call highest
score search averaging clusters on the
note that we are allowed to put on the
tree so I can put a socialization
cluster on a node internal node on the
tree if if all the samples that cover
Leafs under that node have enough
support end of repair support and then
the ease of the version is that if I'm
allowed to put one cluster on it on a
node and also on his parents I would
favor to put it on the parent so with
this we can easily have an attribute the
algorithm that iteratively select sv
clusters with highest score high support
from our list and place them on the on
the tree we can update the scores
accordingly and we can also have some
more complex scoring functions which are
not going to details based on the
variant allele frequency of each sub
clone or node so we tested our algorithm
on the same data that I described this
is the tree obtained by lychee and those
nodes which are marked X or the whole
genome are those samples that we had
whole genome sequencing as well
so we compare the result with common law
which is which does not utilize the tree
and has the similar objective function
and we can show that using the tree we
can predict more somatic search aviation
events even when we have when you use
this the same criteria to cover the same
amount of discordant reads so we can
reduce the false negative the false
negative score so here is an example of
the tree when we have found some kernel
structuration events in that in one of
the patients so so you can see like we
can put 60 lesions which are only seen
in only three of the samples on that
soft loan and you can we also found one
in version with pretty hires support in
all but the lymph sample here is also
another example which are which we are
excited about their if you can see in I
gb when you look at the wreath depths
signal and here is a somatic inversion
which we found on IG so with this I
would like to acknowledge my
collaborators for economic theory across
the road in UC Davis and my
collaborators stand for universe
shoulds
iman in the algorithm we take the tree
as written in stone given by a chi or
some other algorithm did you try and
look forward you have a better fit with
the suboptimal career yeah that's a
great question here we are looking at
that too so we in our like formulation
we would allow to add some nodes on the
tree as well if they are missing similar
question is can be used any other data
streams assists the construction so when
you have ambiguities can use some other
type of data in theory we can but we
haven't looked at it but yeah in theory
we can we can also use it
what's the resolution of the detection
so I notice that most of the cases where
relations of small Canadian so the
particular look at deletion which are
more than 50 base / so they can be very
small no no no they so they are like an
integer number based on the number of
parent read from the data so for example
to have it just has them there's has to
be more read supporting it than the ones
that are high in the tree that's to use
say like the number of reads that
support it locally versus the number of
reads that dome as a pseudo very little
frequency and have it closer yeah
exactly hmm yeah